your series is dealing with stuff that
like a lot of us want to see I think so
yeah this is the truth is that when I
pitched it because I came in and I
pitched my own idea you know I didn't
come in and say like what about baby Han
Solo you know what I mean like it was
like I was like what I'm really
interested in is I'm really interested
uh Star Wars for the perspective of the
bad guys therefore if we set something
earlier in the timeline something before
the prequels but a little bit after you
know end of a high Republic I was like
then the Jedi become you know because
Star Wars is always about Rebels versus
institutional threat right underdogs
versus huge Empire right so if if we
said it then then the Jedi become the
antagonist it's not the bad guys but
they become the bad guys to the bad guys
and I gotta say Kathy really responded
to that she really felt like that was a
pocket of the universe that we had not
seen that nobody else had pitched her
and so I continued to develop it I
turned it into my elevator pitch I
turned it into a bigger larger pitch for
an overall season and series and then I
did a little rip reel for her so
honestly doing what I did today felt
very much like pitching Kathy again I
got I want to stop you there because one
of the things that that a lot of fans
won't know and I sort of want you to
actually talk about it please yes the
fact that like Kathy gets a lot of
online yeah but but I know that she was
the one who made this show oh 100 and I
think I want people to realize that
there were maybe people in the orbit
that were not on board with this show
well I think it was here's what I'll say
I think it's difficult to do a show that
is critical in any way of the Jedi and I
think that you saw that with Ryan's film
do you know what I mean like I think you
I think that I think that that
especially in that moment people were
very nervous about saying
this particular institution may not be
the light and uh you know perfect
stunning group of Heroes that are
totally nobly intentioned and when one
thing that I think Dave would say is
that they they are fallible that's
really the story that George told with
the prequels right is is the default of
this particular group so to me I went
well then what happened right before
that you know he sort of starts in media
res and and Phantom right like and so I
went well if you went back further you
know where are the cracks in the system
how can evil start to rise in the way
that it does to the point where
literally one of the strongest Sith that
ever lived can infiltrate the Senate and
none of the Jedi know about it so I
think once you can kind of get people
into that place then they're more
supportive but I think when you think
you're going to tell the story about bad
guys and the Jedis might be the
antagonist to that to those Jedis I
think that makes people nervous but it
didn't make Kathy nervous and I and I
will say that that room when I pitched
her it was it was probably probably one
of the most exciting things because it
was it was it felt like a conversation
unless like I was up for a job sure you
know what I mean like it felt much more
like okay but what are you gonna do
about this and what are you gonna do
about that and so I was able to like
fold in what I know about Star Wars and
what I love about Star Wars into what
she's always pushing for which is well
what's the emotional through life